Ngày bán mười thống em một chíu tiên tổ chức lấy kiện nghiệm, bán mười năm tháng lập không quan tại sân bay khăn mà
phát biểu tại sự kia nhá lãnh đạo Kim Chương Nguyễn Mạnh tâm quan trọng
của lực lượng này trong chiến lượng gia đề tổng thề.
Đặc biệt là đối với năng lượng gia đề em nhé ngui nhớn, ông chưa biết không quan sẽ được chẳng
Mỹ có khi tại quân sự chiến lượng mới, nhằm đáp ở những nhiễm vụ quan trọng trong sự đảng tới.
Tại bồi lẽ ông Kim Chương Nguyễn chỉ mạnh chiến viễn của các đơn vị bay,
mà thăm dự chương trình nghệ thật trọng, ông cũng chào hình chương Kim Chương Nguyễn cho lực lượng không quan
thế hiện sự vi nhận của mình nhóm đối với bay trọng của lượng này.
Theo dưới phần tích, chứ tiên đăng tốt đầy quá trình hề đại quá quân đội thông thường,
trong đó ở không quan là một chú của quân trọng.
Năm này, bình nhóm lần đầu tụi chương diễn tập không đối không bán đạn thật.
Đông thơi giới thiệu hệ thống cảnh báo sớm và kiểm soát chính không.
Nhưng đồng thấy này cho thấy nỗ lực tăng cường,
nó lực tát chiến phục vụ một tiêu chiến lực dài hạn của đến lạnh.